merci d'être présent nombreux pour
traiter de de du thème de cette première
table ronde de ce premier temps de
réflexion entre nous pour ces 10 ans
alors vous le savez nous avons décidé
cette année de placer nos universités
sur le thème s'engager pour un monde
plus juste lors des journées
parlementaires qui ont précédé nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion de travailler
sur la transition énergétique sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
sur le progrès social et sur les
questions de de fiscalité donc ce soir
nous allons autour de notre ministre
sergent-noël Barrault travailler sur la
question et réfléchir sur la question de
l'innovation pour maîtriser son destin
alors nos invités ont tous répondu
présent à l'appel merci beaucoup
mesdames messieurs pour être pour être à
nos côtés alors je vais vous présenter
très rapidement vous nous redirez un mot
ensuite de qui vous êtes donc je
commence par les dames nous avons
Fabienne Cola qui est la présidente de
la Mutualité Française de Bretagne merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation nous
nous avons Laetitia Vasseur qui est
co-fondatrice de hop donc halte à
l'obsolescence programmée une
association dont vous nous direz
exactement ce que vous faites c'est très
intéressant et puis nous avons Asma là
qui chercheuse et avec qui nous
échangerons notamment de sur les
problématiques de la souveraineté
numérique mais pas que voilà bien
évidemment autour de notre ministre nous
avons notre président du groupe
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
donc Jean-Paul Mattei et puis Jean-Luc
La Gleize ancien député qui qui est
également à nos côtés merci d'être là
alors l'innovation on en parle souvent
pour la technologie ou pour le monde
économique on en parle moins aujourd'hui
pour l'innovation sociale quoique de
plus en plus on aborde ces thématiques
on va aborder la triple dimension
aujourd'hui de l'innovation sur la
souveraineté les questions de
souveraineté les questions de climat et
de transition énergétique et puis bien
sûr l'innovation sociale alors sans plus
tarder je vais passer la parole à notre
ministre qui va nous dire quelques
propos introductifs merci beaucoup
Marina bonjour à toutes et à tous très
heureux d'être à Guidel cette année de
10e anniversaire vous avez entendu
François tout à l'heure en réalité c'est
un c'est un pèlerinage et ça prend tout
son sens de se retrouver dans les
premiers jours de la rentrée ensemble
pour renouer le lien humain qui est si
important quand on est embarqué dans une
aventure collective comme la nôtre mais
aussi de se poser de faire un pas de
côté et je crois que c'est une
singularité de notre famille politique
pour regarder au loin et avant de de
rentrer chacun dans nos territoires dans
nos dans nos activités professionnelles
dans nos vies dès le locaux ou
parlementaires et bien d'avoir les idées
claires et c'est important d'avoir les
idées claires dans la période qui
s'ouvre puisque il y a un an on ne
pouvait pas imaginer que les quatre
saisons qui allaient s'écouler elle est
venue avec leur lot d'incertitude je
pense à l'automne dernier juste après la
neuvième édition de de Guidel ou on a vu
le grand retour de l'inflation avec la
hausse des prix de l'énergie la hausse
des prix des matières premières qui a
complètement bousculé nos modèles
économiques et qui nous a amenés
d'ailleurs au Gouvernement au Parlement
à prendre des mesures inédites qu'on
n'avait jamais vu depuis bien longtemps
pour bloquer les prix et pour
accompagner en tout cas pour essayer de
limiter l'impact de l'inflation mais
l'inflation est là et elle nous amène à
repenser complètement un certain nombre
de choses elle bouscule nos certitudes
après l'automne l'hiver et c'est la
guerre aux portes de l'Europe qui est là
aussi nous amène bouscule complètement
nos certitudes en matière géopolitique
et nous amène à regarder l'avenir avec
un œil très différent au printemps c'est
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
l'élection par les Français d'une
Assemblée nationale pluraliste alors on
va pas complètement se plaindre nous
autres qui sommes des démocrates et qui
avons plaidé pour le pluralisme à
l'Assemblée depuis si longtemps
n'empêche que là aussi sur le plan
institutionnel avec une présence
très forte à l'extrême gauche d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires qui ne
sont pas là pour faire le jeu du
Parlement mais plutôt pour semer le
désordre et le et le chaos ça nous
appelle évidemment à revoir complètement
nos habitudes de travail on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec Jean-Paul Mathey
François Bayrou les ministres et les
membres des groupes parlementaires bref
une nouvelle manière de travailler en
démocratie et puis l'été dernier ça a
été rappelé par nos parlementaires
bretons l'été de tous les records avec
des pointes de température à 30 degrés
en Méditerranée ouest des records
d'impact de foudre les records en
matière d'incendie ou d'épisodes de
sécheresse sur l'ensemble du territoire
des centaines de communes qui ont vu le
l'eau courante s'arrêter au robinet bref
une très forte interpellation des
consciences sur le sujet de la
transition écologique et là aussi sans
doute des certitudes profondément
ébranlées et donc face à ces quatre
saisons d'incertitude il y a deux camps
il y a d'un côté le camp
du repli du renoncement de l'aquabonisme
comme dirait François Bayrou
c'est-à-dire et bien que je vais me
retourner sur mon jardin et me
désintéresser de la marge du monde
puisqu’après tout est perdu et puis un
autre camp et je crois que c'est le
nôtre qui est celui de l'action de
l'ambition de l'audace et en particulier
de l'innovation dans les domaines que
Marina a évoqué que ce soit la
technologie que ce soit le domaine
social que ce soit le domaine
environnemental pour surmonter ces
incertitudes et construire un chemin
pour l'avenir pour l'avenir de notre
pays et pour l'avenir de nos enfants et
je me suis donc très heureux que mode
Gatel et que l'équipe du MoDem est
retenue cette question pour ouvrir nos
universités d'entrée merci je pense
qu'on peut déjà l'applaudir
alors vous l'avez vu vous avez la
possibilité de nous poser des questions
par SMS qu'on prendra en fin de séance
alors sans plus tarder on va parler
souveraineté donc innovation est
souveraineté alors cher Asma quand on a
préparé cette essence cet échange on a
abordé ensemble la question de la
souveraineté technologique au sens large
et vous m'avez précisé que l'enjeu
géopolitique était un enjeu fondamental
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
oui alors avant de d'entrer pile-poil
dans le sujet il faut déjà essayer de
définir tous ensemble ce dont on parle
donc à quoi ce concept de souveraineté
numérique ou plus exactement
technologique renvoi et c'est toujours
un tout petit peu compliqué en réalité
plutôt que de parler de souveraineté
parce que
en termes de droit la France est un pays
souverain il y a des transferts de
compétences vers l'Union européenne mais
factuellement bon je rentre pas dans les
détails il serait peut-être plus juste
de parler à la suite du président de la
République d'autonomie stratégique et
pourquoi parce que l'enjeu sous-jacent
de la question de la souveraineté
technologique c'est la question non pas
d'un protectionnisme non pas d'un repli
sur soi non pas donc d'un techno
souverainisme ou d'un techno
nationalisme comme une partie
aujourd'hui de l'échiquier disons des
experts en France voilà il y a une
espèce de tentation sur ces sujets là
mais qui en fait sont aveugles des
enjeux géopolitiques et surtout sont
aveugles de ce qu'est le cyberespace et
ce qu'est Internet j'y reviendrai
peut-être du coup la question simplement
c'est plutôt la question du rapport de
force c'est-à-dire comment est-ce qu'on
construit une vision politique
industrielle stratégique qui donne à la
France les moyens de contrer les
incertitudes dont on a parler en début
en ouverture de l'Université de de
rentrer et qui donne donc les leviers
d'un rapport de force d'abord vis-à-vis
de ses de ses ennemis mais surtout en
réalité vis-à-vis de ces alliés parce
que souvent nos alliés ne sont pas nos
ennemis et donc dans ce nouveau
échiquier géopolitique qui est en
mouvement qui est fragmenté qui est
compliqué ou les alliances sont en train
de se redéfinir de s'approfondir ou des
distances sont en train d'être prises
cette question là devient fondamentale
alors tout à l'heure je disais ça pose
un certain nombre de questions
géopolitiques industrielle mais aussi
philosophique c'est-à-dire en fait quel
est le la place de la France dans un
monde qui aujourd'hui est
fondamentalement malgré tout
interdépendant alors pourquoi
interdépendant parce que l'économie de
la donnée l'économie numérique ce sont
des flux permanents donc qui diffusent
des mouvements des allers-retours et ce
qui crée aujourd'hui la valeur c'est
bien l'économie de la donnée c'est bien
c'est donner là ces informations là qui
sont transmises
une fois qu'on a dit ça ça suppose donc
de se dire quelle stratégie on construit
dans ces interdépendants là et là où il
y a un sujet géopolitique majeur c'est
qu'on se rencontre que dans ce
cyberespace et bien il y a une
fragmentation de cet espace au niveau
mondial c'est à dire que l'Internet
mondial l'utopie initiale qu'il a qu'il
a un peu construit en réalité et en
train de se déconstruire par qui par la
Chine la Russie l'Iran aussi d'une
certaine manière c'est ce qu'on appelle
si je devais jargonner le spleen ternet
c'est à dire la balkanisation du
cyberespace et donc à partir de ce
moment là se pose la question de quel
est nous notre position notre stratégie
dans le camp occidental et à partir de
ce moment là on comprend la souveraineté
non pas comme étant simplement un
concept national mais un concept peut
être beaucoup plus élargi beaucoup plus
solidaire au niveau occidental s'oppose
donc la question de notre rapport de nos
alliances avec les États-Unis et c'est
un sujet qui est pas du tout anodin
parce qu'en France on a beaucoup pris ce
sujet là par la question du Cloud
[Musique]
merci
c'est vrai que on a plus le droit de
dire
récemment donc dans l'info nuagic
qui
a beaucoup préempté le débat en France à
tort à mon avis parce qu'en fait on a on
a on a fermé le sujet de notre
souveraineté technologique autour de la
question simplement du cloud poussait
d'ailleurs par les acteurs de
l'écosystème pour des histoires aussi de
business
et peut-être pas forcément à tort
d'ailleurs mais ça a donc en fait
occulter l'ensemble de la chaîne
technologique c'est-à-dire en fait les
trois couches du CBR espace d'abord les
infras il y a aussi la question des
câbles sous-marins des satellites de
l'ensemble de l'infrastructure dure
parce que c'est aussi une économie qui
est fondamentalement matérielle
dont le Cloud fait partie mais le Cloud
ne présente pas tout le sujet il y a la
question logicielle les Software et puis
ensuite il y a la question et tout à
l'heure on l'a évoqué l'incertitude
démocratique qu'est-ce qui fait que
demain on va pouvoir continuer à faire
société et là se pose donc le lien avec
ma dernière couche du cyber espace qui
est la couche sémantique et là qu'est-ce
qu'on voit apparaître dans ce spleen
carnet dans ce dans cette internet qui
est balconisé ce sont les guerres
informationsnelles ce que Poutine
appellerait d'ailleurs appelle
d'ailleurs la souveraineté
informationnelle et donc en fait ces
trois couches là sont parfaitement
interdépendantes et pour comprendre la
question de la souveraineté
technologique il faut absolument avoir
cette vision systémique d'un point de
vue plus technique à smack quand on a
échangé vous m'aviez dit il faut aussi
qu'on fasse des choix et qu'on sache
faire des choix ce qui peut comporter
une part de renoncement parfois
absolument chaque choix est un
renoncement et donc de façon très
concrète il s'agit de se dire quelle est
la la politique industrielle
technologique qu'on construit il ne
suffit pas de dire on va mettre entre 1
milliard sur l'IA un milliard sur un peu
quelques centaines de millions sur le
mot mort les nouvelles générations de
chiffrement un peu de Cloud et et des
drones il va falloir être beaucoup plus
précis que ça et pour ça il faut qu'on
ait une vision très claire sur nos
filières et surtout les filières qui
réussissent et celles qui sont beaucoup
plus en difficulté tout à l'heure je
disais la question c'est la question du
rapport de force et qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'il nous faut
collectivement ceux qui sont en
responsabilité aussi définir en fait où
sont nos forces nos assets nos actifs
dans la chaîne de valeur technologiques
mondiale donc où est-ce qu'on de façon
très précise très chirurgicale on
investit et donc ce à quoi on renonce
aussi mais de façon à pouvoir être si
vous voulez
indispensable et que le rapport est
qu'on soit en fait tout simplement pas
ridicule dans le rapport de force on
arrive à maintenir les équilibres
quelque part d'équilibre d'ailleurs
c'est la terminologie de Emmanuel Macron
je crois absolument alors on parle
beaucoup de sobriété notamment dans le
numérique puisqu'on sait que le
numérique est un consommateur important
selon vous est-ce que donc la sobriété
numérique telle qu'on commence à
l'envisager et on y reviendrait ensuite
derrière notamment avec avec Laetitia et
plutôt un pilier ou un frein pour notre
souveraineté comment vous voyez les
choses c'est ni un pilier ni un frein
c'est un prérequis c'est à dire qu'en
réalité il va falloir très vite et plus
que il va falloir on le fait déjà en
réalité
concilier à la fois sobriété et
souveraineté alors encore une fois dans
le débat public ce qui peut revenir à
vos oreilles quand on lit un peu les
médias mainstream c'est
on a l'impression que ça serait
antinomique or pas du tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les territoires
est hyper intéressant je prends
l'exemple de l'agglomération de La
Rochelle par exemple pardon je n'ai pas
d'exemple breton mais ça vous aurez
tarder j'espère ou alors il y a
peut-être quelqu'un dans la salle qui me
donnera le contre-exemple mais
typiquement l'agglomération de La
Rochelle et en train de construire sa
feuille de route territoire intelligent
donc Smart City exactement sur ça sur
une espèce de triptyque zéro gafam on
veut pas d'acteur américain donc on est
appuyé sur l'écosystème d'innovation
locale avec des start-up locales avec
des datas qui sont aujourd'hui hébergées
dans à la fac dans dans l'université de
La Rochelle et puis l'objectif derrière
c'est d'avoir un territoire zéro carbone
donc c'est bien une stratégie de
décarbonation du territoire et en ce
sens la technologie peut être un outil
formidable de mapping de compréhension
des usages des consommations et donc
pour jauger là où il faut en mettre plus
là où il faut en mettre moins auprès de
qui sur quelle saison etc donc la data
c'est aussi ça
d'accord merci Asma alors laetitia a
chopé kezako expliquez-nous parce qu'on
est en plein dans la thématique
forcément de l'évolution du numérique
aujourd'hui et des usages oui bonjour
donc à choper on s'est plutôt hop qu'on
dit en général mais ça donc ça s'appelle
halte à une association que j'ai créée
en 2015 et qui vise à allonger la durée
de vie des produits à s'attaquer à ce
phénomène d'obsolescence programmée ou
prématuré c'est à dire le fait que les
produits tout simplement ne dure pas
assez ne sont pas prévus conçus pour
durer de manière assez durable et
réparable et derrière il y a énormément
de conséquences on est vraiment à la
jonction d'une thématique à la fois très
environnementale mais aussi très
consommateur on parlait tout à l'heure
d'inflation de pouvoir d'achat
clairement le fait de pouvoir garder ses
produits plus longtemps de ne pas être
contraint de les de les renouveler trop
souvent c'est un sujet purement
consommation également et cette
obsolescence elle se décline de
plusieurs leur manière donc ce qui nous
fait toucher un large spectre de sujet
tout d'abord l'obsolescence matériel
donc là on parle vraiment des objets de
leurs conception de leur design mais de
tous les objets de tous les secteurs
mais surtout electriquer électronique je
dirais mais également cette obsolescence
de plus en plus importante dans notre
vie dans nos vies quotidiennes et
industriel qui est l'obsolescence
logiciel parce que de plus en plus de
produits sont dotés de numérique de
Digital et cette obsolescence qui
parfois est programmée ou prématurée
pose de d'énormes questions sur la durée
de vie de ces équipements et puis le
dernier aspect c'est l'obsolescence
esthétique ou culturel qui interroge nos
modes de pensée nos modes de
consommation sur la désirabilité du
renouvellement aussi parfois les
appareils durs encore on pourrait durer
pour être réparé et pour autant on n'a
pas forcément le réflexe de le faire
alors vous conduisez plusieurs actions
vous avez des publications est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus par
exemple sur le club de la durabilité
parce que très intéressant puisqu'on
parle aujourd'hui de souveraineté de
croissance finalement quelque part c'est
que vous arrivez à lier ce que vous
faites sur le l'obsolescence programmée
la lutte contre l'obsolescence
programmée et vous êtes en train de
créer un nouveau un nouvel écosystème
autour justement de ce sujet oui j'aime
bien avoir une approche systémique par
rapport à ces sujets en fait on a
plusieurs modes d'action un gros pilier
pour nous c'est le plaidoyer parce qu'on
pense que c'est important que justement
les les décideurs publics et privés
prennent des engagements mais des
engagements qui s'imposent à tous parce
qu'on a besoin de ça aujourd'hui pour
aller plus vite dans la transition
écologique et en même temps on a besoin
de répondre à des questions qui sont
fondamentalement économiques
l'obsolescence programmée ou prématurée
c'est un enjeu tout simplement pour
renouveler les produits mais du coup
pour renouveler les ventes et donc la
croissance les emplois et donc la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait
une obsolescence sans une économie sans
obsolescence et donc évidemment cet
enjeu c'est l'économie circulaire
[Musique]
pour l'économie circulaire parce que une
innovation qui ne prendrait pas en
compte les enjeux écologiques seraient
déjà obsolètes tout simplement parce que
on peut avoir il faut vraiment je pense
penser l'innovation regarde de son
impact bien sûr parfois il y a un impact
qui est recherché de performance
géopolitique etc mais finalement si elle
est elle va contre des un impact
écologique positif ou un impact social
elle se retourne contre nous et
l'innovation c'est se projeter dans
l'avenir l'innovation du coup c'est de
savoir comment on va vivre dans 10 ans
15 ans qu'elles seront les répercussions
sur le long terme de nos investissements
d'aujourd'hui et évidemment il faut il
faut s'adapter à cette résilience
nécessaire s'adapter au changement
climatique et quand j'entends voilà
cette ces innovations sur le numérique
je pense que c'est passionnant il faut
bien avoir aussi en tête comme vous le
disiez très bien toute l'infrastructure
qui va avec
tout ce qui est Smart City il faut que
ça soit proposer au regard de
l'investissement que ça va prendre en
terme écologique sur les device 20 sur
les je dis pas de voilà c'est moi
anglais sur les sur les terminaux qui
est heureux représentent 80% de
l'empreinte environnementale donc il
faut pas non plus tomber de combat et
avoir la vision holistique pour pouvoir
faire les bons investissements justement
je pense sur l'avenir d'accord merci
beaucoup Laetitia alors quand on parle
de résilience il y a des secteurs qui
ont plus souffert que d'autres ces
derniers temps cher Jean-Luc toi tu as
beaucoup travaillé à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment sur la question de
de l'aéronautique puisque tu es un élu
un peu territorialement concerné par ses
problématiques alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le secteur aéronautique
est décrié montrer du droit par certains
et pour autant c'est un enjeu qui est
stratégique pour notre pays alors
comment aujourd'hui ce secteur opère sa
mue qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire sur
le sujet
d'abord que je vienne Toulouse et donc
effectivement je me sens assez concerné
par par l'aéronautique
et donc je voudrais juste vous ramener
il y a deux ans c'est pas il y a un
siècle c'était il y a deux ans nous
étions en train il y avait pas il y
avait pas l'inflation il y avait pas
l'Ukraine mais il y avait la covid et au
moment où la crise de la covid a éclaté
les le transport aérien s'est arrêté
90% des avions étaient cloués au sol et
un an un tiers des compagnies aériennes
mondiales à déposer le bilan
pendant ce temps là on était nous en
confinement j'avais mes voisins autour
de Toulouse qui se travaille tous dans
les Renault nautiques qui passaient leur
temps des agazons deux fois par semaine
ou trois fois par semaine donc des
ingénieurs des gens qui en fait ne
produisaient plus pour la France et j'ai
eu peur à la fois peur que c'est un
impact très très très fort sur notre
pays cette crise du covid et qui se
combinait avec la honte de prendre
l'avion le flic Sam qui est inventé par
une jeune suédoise
et donc j'ai vraiment
j'ai demandé en fait à l'Assemblée
nationale de lancer de mission qu'elle
m'a confié sur l'avenir de
l'aéronautique et ça déclarbonation
pourquoi déjà parce que l'aéronautique
aujourd'hui en France sont presque 300
000 emplois industriels de pointe sur
ces 300.000 emplois industriels de
pointe il y en a un peu plus de 100 000
dans la région toulousaine mais si on
rajoute la région paloise et bordelaise
ça nous fait 170 000 personnes sur le
Sud-Ouest c'est 40% des emplois
industriels donc c'est quand même pas
rien et c'est aussi le secteur le
premier secteur qui contribue à la
balance économique extérieure française
si on n'a pas l'industrie aéronautique
on ne vend quasiment rien à l'extérieur
la France est l'un des rares pays du
monde à savoir faire un avion de A à Z
on a également les États-Unis qui savent
le faire
on pense que les Chinois savent le faire
mais pour l'instant ils n'ont certifié
aucun avion à l'international donc on a
vraiment un savoir-faire extraordinaire
et c'est un secteur qui est quand même
beaucoup attaqué sur un plan émission de
graisse à effet de serre et donc j'ai
voulu en avoir le cœur net est-ce que
c'est vrai ce que c'est pas vrai ce que
ça exagéré à ce que c'est pas exagéré
parce qu'on a quand même pas mal
l'habitude d'avoir des écologistes qui
prennent de plus en plus de place mais
dans le sol et unique objectif et la
décroissance voilà et donc est-ce que
c'était pas effectivement un discours
de ce genre là donc c'est pour ça que je
me suis lancé là dedans la situation
française européenne est-ce qu'elle est
très différente aujourd'hui tu as parlé
des États-Unis notamment ce qu'on a des
points de vigilance particulière à
maintenir en terme d'innovation sur ce
secteur
c'est un secteur qui innove déjà depuis
longtemps il faut savoir que au moins
cher bus chaque nouvelle génération
d'avions consomme entre 20 et 25%
de
carburant de moins que la génération
précédente donc ça veut dire qu'elle
émet aussi 20 à 25% de moins de gaz à
effet de serre donc ça c'est du à
l'amélioration du poids c'est du à
l'amélioration des peintures c'est du un
des
turbines qui sont beaucoup plus
efficientes et donc ça fait déjà une
vingtaine d'années que ceci est
en route mais il y a également d'autres
recherches qui sont qui sont mises en
place des recherches plus dans
l'équipement de l'aéroport tout
simplement un avion qui est sur
l'aéroport en général utilisent ces
moteurs pour produire sa propre
électricité à l'intérieur donc ça il y a
des choses qui sont à faire la plupart
des opérations des aéroports modernes
Toulouse est un aéroport moderne ont des
prises pour plugger non branché pour
brancher la viande directement sur le
c'est des avions circulaires
directement pour brancher le l'avion sur
l'électricité de l'aéroport et pour ne
pas faire tourner les les moteurs il y a
également des on peut apprendre des
techniques de pilotage
différentes aujourd'hui les pilotes sont
obligés de suivre un certain nombre de
routes qui sont préprogrammés et donc
ils n'utilisent pas
la 4D au sens où la quatrième dimension
c'est le temps et aujourd'hui à
l'instant précis avec les vents avec la
météo et autres
du vol on devrait pouvoir calculer et on
a des outils numériques qui permettent
de le faire calculer quel serait la
trajectoire idéale pour pour cet avion
là voilà il y a beaucoup de
d'innovations numériques à mettre en
place autour des avions
elles sont les carburants il y a encore
il y a des choses qui sont
qui existent aujourd'hui on peut avoir
du carburant durable
à partir de copeaux de bois à partir de
graisses animales à partir de résidus
d'huile on peut déjà faire donc à partir
d'une certaine biomasse on peut faire du
carburant durable ça existe Airbus a
fait un vol entre Toulouse et les
Montréal avec un avion en A320 qui était
100% avec ce type de carburant à part à
base d'huile voilà
donc c'est possible sauf que ce
carburant là il est à base de biomasse
la biomasse n'est pas infinie et donc il
y a des recherches qui sont actuellement
en cours et qui montrent que l'on peut
également produire du carburant durable
à partir
et de CO2 capté dans l'atmosphère donc
vous avez de l'hydrogène sur les
archives soit vert et vous capter de CO2
dans l'atmosphère vous créez un
carburant qui est utilisable dans
l'aviation
les tous les moteurs d'avion aujourd'hui
disponibles en France en tout cas cher
Airbus sont certifiés pour pouvoir
utiliser 50% de carburant durable mais
en fait dans les faits ils peuvent
utiliser 100% de carburant durable c'est
notamment le vol entre Toulouse et
Montréal qui l'a montré voilà donc il y
a vraiment beaucoup de choses à faire
il y a également des recherches sur
l'électrique l'hydrogène et les
carburants durables tout simplement
parce que
très court courrier par exemple entre
deux régions françaises ou de région
européennes on pourra on estime qu'à
horizon 10 ans on pourra avoir des
avions électriques avec des batteries ça
c'est tout à fait possible
sur un vol moyen terme on pourra
éventuellement avoir des avions à
hydrogène donc l'hydrogène pouvant à la
fois générer soit de l'électricité pour
un moteur électrique soit être
directement brûlé dans les réacteurs
par contre pour les vols très très très
long courrier les batteries sont trop
lourdes le volume de l'hydrogène est
trop important donc pour pas y arriver
donc il faudra obligatoirement qu'il y
ait au moins en vol une possibilité
d'avoir du carburant durable
c'est-à-dire que l'avion décollera en
mode électrique arrivera jusqu'à son
altitude de vol puis basculera en mode
carburant durable puis arrivé à
proximité de son aéroport d'arrivée il
rebascurera en mode électrique donc
voilà les recherches aujourd'hui que que
la France est en train de faire qui est
que la France que airbus est en train de
faire et que l'Europe est en train de
faire
les Américains ne sont pas loin derrière
et notamment sont bien aidés par Joe
Biden qui a lancé beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent dans notamment dans le
carburant durable
avec justement l'aéronautique pour faire
un Paris New York en 30 minutes et donc
je me demande si la variable du temps ne
compte pas aussi dire en compressant le
temps on pollue peut-être un peu moins
et donc il y a peut-être des
argumentaire c'est l'argumentaire qui
est en tout cas pousser comme d'habitude
à la Silicon Valley en tout cas on voit
bien que c'est industrie qui opère sa
mue finalement elle va être de plus en
plus acceptable au regard du coup
écologique qu'elle pouvait représenter
et qui a vraiment une révolution
industrielle autour de la transition
énergétique qui est en train de s'opérer
y compris je regarde Jimmy sur le
transport maritime aujourd'hui où il y a
vraiment des technologies qui se mettent
qui se mettent en place alors il faut
quand même avoir des chiffres qui sont
qui sont
parlant aujourd'hui le transport aérien
c'est pas aujourd'hui en 2019 c'était au
moment où il y avait une pointe très
très forte le plus gros
la plus grosse pointe de trafic aérien
c'était en 2019 parce qu'en 2020 il y a
eu la covid donc maintenant ça
ça remonte sauf pour les vols
internationaux
transcontinentaux l'Asie par exemple est
totalement fermée
la production de gaz à effet de serre
générée par l'aviation en France
représente 3% des gaz effet de serre et
mis par la France donc remettons les
choses alors juste valeur qu'est-ce qui
coûte le plus cher en termes de
démission de graisse effet de serre en
termes de transport en France c'est la
route la route fait jusqu'à 90% des gaz
à effet de serre le train en fait très
très peu
sous réserve qu'ils ont électrique et
que l'électricité se verse ce qu'on a
encore des machines des michelines
diesel merci Jean-Luc donc un territoire
très imprégné de l'aéronautique et nous
espérons que nous arriverons grâce à
l'innovation à préserver ses emplois et
donc ça me permet de faire le lien avec
les territoires et l'innovation sociale
sur les territoires donc je me retourne
vers vous Fabienne Colas merci d'être là
donc vous êtes présidente de la
Mutualité Française de Bretagne qui est
un mouvement affilié à la Fédération
Nationale de la Mutualité et qui
regroupe aujourd'hui 164 mutuelles
adhérentes plus de 4700 collaborateurs
et c'est plus d'un million 650 000
personnes qui sont protégées si mes
chiffres sont bons voilà alors vous avez
tenu votre congrès en septembre tout
début septembre à Marseille et vous avez
dévoilé votre raison d'être est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer merci
avant tout j'excuse
Eric Chenu qui est le président de la
Mutualité Française vous pouvez pas être
parmi vous ce soir et c'est la première
fois que je représente publiquement j'ai
intégré le cadre de la Mutualité
française il y a peu de temps donc je
pense que c'est une forme de bizutage
donc vous m'excuserez si je
ouais c'est le côté solidaire de la
mutualité
alors effectivement on sort de notre 43e
congrès j'en dis juste un petit mot
parce qu'il est clair aussi notre raison
d'être le titre c'était mutualité
territoire d'engagement pour l'entraide
et les solidarités et en fait au sein de
ce congrès on a mis l'accent sur
l'innovation l'action les initiatives
mutualistes
l'objectif c'était que les militants
repèrent les initiatives intéressantes
pour qu'ensuite ils puissent les SMS sur
l'ensemble des territoires et tout ça en
résonance avec des aspirations de la
société
on a donc dévoilé notre raison d'être
alors je sais pas s'il y a des
mutualistes dans la salle mais en tout
cas je vais la partager avec vous
elle est assez courte parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a des raisons d'être qui
sont parfois un petit peu quand même
plus complexe à mémoriser
se protéger mutuellement aujourd'hui
pour ensemble construire les solidarités
de demain
voilà donc chaque mot bien sûr à son à
son importance l'enjeu de notre raison
d'être en fait c'était d'expliciter la
manière dont le mouvement mutualiste
entend être utile à la société
voilà c'est en quoi les mutuelles elles
participent de elles apportent des
solutions aux conflictualité et aux
transitions qui sont qui sont en cours
et qui affectent et qui vont affecter
malheureusement le système de santé de
protection sociale et la société dans
son ensemble voilà dans ce que je peux
dire dans la formulation de notre raison
d'être c'est qu'on est un petit peu
revenu au fondement de la mutualité donc
ça je pense que vous connaissez c'est à
dire c'est des hommes des femmes qui se
rassemblent pour être plus fort et pour
se protéger des aléas
voilà et donc nous on est persuadé que
c'est que la solidarité c'est la
meilleure façon de surmonter les
obstacles
donc finalement on peut dire que votre
mouvement
s'encre dans ce qu'on appelle les
sociétés à mission même si c'est un
mouvement mutualiste et d'ailleurs même
en matière de recherche et d'innovation
vous être vous êtes très engagé puisque
vous avez j'ai envie de dire avec un
petit jeu de mot réussi votre pari
puisque vous avez été L'Oréal donc du
prix avenir recherche innovation
notamment sur deux projets à un projet
ronron-thérapie qui parlera certains
pour ceux qui aiment les chats voilà
mais le second projet dont peut-être
vous pouvez nous dire un mot live
companion voilà si vous pouvez nous
expliquer
ces prix que vous avez reçu
déjà ce qu'on peut dire que la Mutualité
est fait mouvement depuis 120 ans donc
c'est plutôt une vieille dame et en même
temps elle a toujours eu l'avenir en
ligne de mire et elle laisse toujours su
s'adapter et innover et donc on aime
bien également mettre en avant
les territoires qui expérimentent et
donc on a créé un prix avec la Fondation
de l'Avenir qui s'appelle donc
le pari et au travers de ce prix en fait
on fait le pari qu'on peut inventer de
nouvelles pratiques
du soin et d'accompagnement et on fait
le pari qu'on va pouvoir favoriser sinon
le bien-être en tout cas le mieux-être
des publics vulnérables voilà donc en
fait on met en avant des approches
parfois non médicalement c'est ce qui
c'est l'exemple du prix qui a été qui a
été remis ici là dans dans la ville de
Guidel donc oui ça s'appelle la
ronronthérapie
en fait on utilise le chat comme outil
de soin auprès de de femmes dépendantes
puisque c'est dans un centre de service
de soins de suite et de réadaptation
qu'on addictologie
car Ludo pour ceux qui connaissent le
centre à Guidel voilà donc on fait le
pari que le chat va permettre aux
patients de se détendre d'exprimer leurs
émotions mais aussi de se
responsabiliser de prendre soin d'elle
mais aussi du du prendre soin de
l'animal voilà pour ce premier exemple
plutôt d'approche non médicamenteux sur
lequel on mise beaucoup
et le deuxième exemple que je voulais
partager avec vous donc là ça s'appelle
l'outil life companion et c'est un outil
qui a été mis en catégorie au centre de
karpables le centre mutualiste de
rééducation fonctionnelle de kerpap et
en fait ça consiste en un assistant
numérique un logiciel qui permet aux
personnes en situation de handicap de
de communiquer et donc de trouver toute
sa place dans la société alors toujours
en matière d'innovation et d'une manière
aussi très locale et c'est un sujet qui
va intéresser Geneviève dariussec notre
ministre vous avez également un projet
innovant un coworkit est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un mot puisque là on
est vraiment à la croisée de cette
innovation sociale qui a aussi derrière
un impact économique je tourne les pages
si on vient donc au projet achité
alors on mise beaucoup nous sur les
territoires on pense que les les qui
vont faire confiance aux acteurs de
terrain et dans notre raison d'être
quand on dit ensemble c'est certes
ensemble entre entités mutualistes qu'on
essaye de construire les solidarités de
demain mais on souhaite aussi le faire
en partenariat avec les élus locaux avec
les acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire en fait aujourd'hui si on veut
innover il faut il faut le faire à
plusieurs et le projet aïchité c'est
vraiment une belle illustration de ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble sur un
territoire donc le projet il est porté
par l'Orient agglomération et il est en
lien étroit avec deux cofondateurs qui
sont le centre mutualiste de kerpap et
puis le Centre d'Innovation biotech
Biotech Santé Bretagne pardon
voilà et ce que je trouve chouette dans
ce projet là c'est qu'en fait on fait du
handicap un atout donc en positive en
fait à partir d'un d'un sujet compliqué
et donc le projet il a pour ambition de
faire du handicap un levier d'innovation
sociale et technologie au service des
citoyens c'est très important tout en
favorisant l'attractivité économique du
territoire donc en fait on mise à la
fois sur un mieux-être des personnes
mais aussi sur
sur l'économie du territoire très bien
mais je vous remercie et Geneviève ça
fera l'objet peut-être d'un futur
déplacement
en tout cas merci beaucoup vous avez
rappelé au travers de votre de votre
propos le lien aussi vous faites avec le
territoire et les élus locaux et on va
voyager un petit moment du côté de
Mayotte alors hélène est dans la salle
ou la saluons Hélène qui a été lu notre
plus jeune conseillère départementale on
la voit elle et elle va
elle nous a préparé une petite vidéo et
on va voir que il y a des territoires
ultramarins ou parfois on peut voir
qu'il y est on pensait qu'il y a des
difficultés mais que on innove partout
sur le territoire national surtout dans
nos territoires
ultramarins et elle nous a donc mis en
avant l'innovation à Mayotte
en Mayotte est un territoire riche et sa
position stratégique fait-elle le point
central du développement économique
industriel et culturel du 21e siècle
pour le rayonnement de la France et de
l'Europe dans l'océan Indien et en
Afrique les projets pour Mayotte sont
nombreux être la base arrière du projet
gazier au Mozambique devenir un grand
hub aérien et maritime sans oublier les
perspectives touristiques avec un des
plus grands et plus beau lagon fermé du
monde Mayotte aime la France et Mayotte
à tant à apporter à la France c'est
pourquoi notre territoire a besoin de
politique ambitieuse alors chers amis
démocrates la prochaine fois qu'on vous
demandera pourquoi Mayotte et française
souvenez-vous de notre devise nous
voulons rester français pour être libre
nous nous en souviendrons merci à toi
alors cher Président on a entendu
beaucoup de choses et en tant que
président de notre groupe et
parlementaire on a beaucoup de travail
et quand on parle innovation je crois
que tu as beaucoup de choses à nous dire
quand on a abordé le sujet tous les deux
tu m'as dit j'ai plein de choses à dire
parce que tu es avant avant d'être
parlementaire aussi un homme
d'entreprise et un élu de terrain donc
comment tu abordes les choses alors
merci Marina bonsoir à tout le monde
quand je vous entends je me dis est-ce
que je suis bien à ma place sur cette
cette tribune innovation et autres mais
je voudrais vous parler on parle
beaucoup de contenu de Fonds
d'innovation vous nous faites rêver avec
plein mais moi j'aimerais évoquer ce
qu'on appelle le contenant les
structures autour et tout le fait le
phénomène des startups et toutes les
structures juridiques que l'on peut
avoir pour accompagner l'innovation
financer l'innovation
législateur est souvent intervenu dans
ce domaine et une des premières fois où
paradoxalement une loi sur la recherche
est venue modifier le statut juridique
de certaines sociétés c'était monsieur
Allègre à l'époque qui avait été
ministre de la Recherche pour après il a
eu des positions qui sont ce qu'elles
sont mais je reviendrai pas notamment
sur le climat mais
il avait compris que recherche
fondamentale et entreprises pouvaient
rimer et notamment les passerelles qu'on
pourrait faire avec l'université et la
recherche fondamentale et moi je pense
que c'est c'est très important et il a
donc permis c'est lui qui a inventé la
SAS la société par action simplifiée
nouvelle formule puisque c'est une
structure juridique qui avait été très
créé en 94 pour faire des joints de
Ventures des plus bel exemple c'était
Eurotunnel mais bon ça au début ça
patinait un peu en Suisse a été mieux
et donc permettent à des sociétés de
capitaux avec des chercheurs à la tête
avec un statut particulier on essaie de
faire évoluer petit à petit et dans les
voies sur la recherche la loi pacte on a
essayé d'avancer mais c'est pas encore
parfait par rapport à ça à mon avis il
faut améliorer donc
juridiquement on a essayé de répondre
par un cadre juridique à l'innovation et
à la recherche
ensuite
moi j'ai eu d'ailleurs une expérience de
création d'une à l'époque c'était un des
années 2000 une forme de startup qui
était dans le dans le milieu juridique
le conseil en ligne j'ai porté pendant
deux ans ce projet avec un de mes
étudiants à l'époque et des amis
entrepreneurs
et à l'époque c'était l'université
d'Hourtin c'était université de la
technologie haute qui est développée et
j'insiste à plusieurs conférences et
puis je regardais moi qui suis un homme
quand même d'entreprise je regardais les
bilans des startups je voyais le capital
pas mal d'immobilisation de recherche et
autres des capitaux importants on avait
été chercher des capitaux dans tous les
sens on va dire et puis un compte de
résultat zéro zéro chiffre d'affaires
donc
j'évite pris peur je me suis dit le
modèle économique où il est puisque à
l'époque c'était une démarche sur
Internet et encore aujourd'hui payer sur
Internet et la publicité n'existait pas
comme ça existe maintenant est un modèle
économique compliqué donc c'est des
structures qui nécessitent de beaucoup
de fonds propres et sur lesquels il y a
un pari sur l'avenir par rapport à ce
que l'on peut rencontrer donc je crois
qu'il faut qu'on les accompagne d'un
point de vue juridique mais il faut
quand même qu'on soit vigilant
c'est-à-dire quand on passe dans un
espèce de de cycle infernal de rachat de
valeur pseudo incorporelle qui en fait
font tourner de la finance et qui
peuvent nous envoyer dans le mur donc on
a quelques exemples qui peuvent faire
peur au niveau de la financement
mondiale donc je crois qu'il faut être
très très vigilant sur sur ce système ça
n'empêche que
nous législateur et on est là pour
écouter aussi toutes les demandes
effectivement on a ce matin on parlait
du crédit pour recherche bien évidemment
c'est une structure la possibilité
d'investir dans les entreprises c'est
une structure c'est une façon de
favoriser l'épargne dans le haut de
bilan des entreprises c'est certaines
exonérations fiscales sur les jeunes
entreprises etc tout un tas d'outils
favorisant je dirais l'innovation donc
start-up oui
mais modèle économiques chiffre
d'affaires marcher ça me semble aussi
vertueux dans le temps pour consolider
des très belles idées il faut qu'elles
aient un marché qu'elle rencontre un
marché et qu'elle faisait une raison
économique me semble-t-il pour que ça
puisse durer dans le temps ensuite
moi qui suis qui suis les entreprises
depuis des années 80 j'ai vu vraiment
évoluer le monde de l'entreprise et avec
la loi pacte vous l'évoquez on évoquait
les entreprises de mission et autres on
a modifié la notion d'objet social d'une
entreprise avec une notion
environnementale une notion sociétale
excessivement importante et je crois que
l'entreprise de d'aujourd'hui
l'entreprise de demain ne sera plus la
même que il y aura le partage de la
richesse nous tenons beaucoup au partage
de la richesse quelle sera à la fois au
niveau la gouvernance au niveau la
répartition des richesses donc il va
falloir être excessivement innovant sur
le contenant
pour pouvoir accompagner un contenu
fondamental il faut que la recherche
fondamentale les expériences qui sont
faites sont nécessaires mais il faut
qu'on puisse trouver le cadre juridique
pour les accompagner mais je dis
attention ne tombons pas dans la folie
de la finance avec je dirais des
sociétés ou des gens qui se manquent sur
le la pertinence je dirais de leur
modèle voilà donc je trouve que
l'innovation nécessite beaucoup de je
dirais de responsabilité puis pour
terminer
il faudrait aussi qu'on s'intéresse aux
entreprises qui existent qui peuvent
elles aussi être des startups dans
l'innovation et dans la diversification
on l'a beaucoup réfléchi au moment où tu
évoqué tout à l'heure Jean-Luc la crise
sanitaire qui a fait que certains
entreprises n'avaient plus de marché
vous se retrouver et nécessité de se
reconvertir et donc là aussi on aurait
pu inventer non seulement il y a un
crédit pour recherche mais il y aurait
pu y avoir aussi un crédit pour
reconversion de certains entreprises
voilà j'irai le champ est immense le
champ est immense il faut qu'on
l'encadre il faut qu'on surveille et
pour que ça puisse durer dans le temps
c'est très belle expérience de très
belles aventures humaines mais pour
qu'elle soit efficace pour notre société
il faut qu'elle s'inscrive dans la durée
donc elle retrouve d'une part un marché
et ensuite qu'elles aient un cadre
juridique
sécurisant pour l'avenir avec peut-être
avant que Asma qui voulait réagir puisse
puisse réagir un nouveau paradigme pour
les parlementaires nationaux que nous
sommes c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est sur
des enjeux qui sont internationaux
notamment quand on parle de numérique
aujourd'hui et donc un cadre législatif
qui s'impose à nous et qui peut être
hors de nos propres frontières voilà
donc peut-être une échelle qui parfois
peut un peu nous échapper en termes de
disposition que nous devons prendre nos
droits national pour accompagner ces
entreprises voilà donc on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec nos collègues
notamment députés européens sur toutes
ces thématiques aujourd'hui liées à
l'innovation ou parfois on peut avoir
cette difficulté
si je peux rebondir sur cette notion il
y a eu une époque ce qu'on appelle la
société européenne on va pas se mentir
pour qu'on ait et on reviendra sur les
questions fiscales pour qu'on ait le cas
juridique c'est peut-être une chose la
société européenne existe le problème
c'est son statut fiscal et social et
donc notre statut fiscal il est national
il y a la notion d'établissement stable
qui font quand une entreprise exerce
dans un pays elle a la fiscalité sociale
de ce pays là dont on n'a pas encore
dépassé on n'a pas réussi à mon sens et
à créer cette espèce de structure
internationale juridique et fiscale
serait peut-être une bonne piste pour
pouvoir loger ses grands projets qui ont
des vocation à être
à l'internation juste un dernier point
j'évoquais la loi pacte l'amélioration
jour de Noël a été très active sur ce
texte là aussi tout ce qui est
propriétaire intellectuelle brevet ou
autre ça c'est également fondamental
dans notre dans notre réflexion nous
sommes un peu moins mauvais qu'avant on
s'améliore et je crois que ça va dans le
bon sens
vraiment une réaction rapide parce que
le point qui vient d'être soulevé et
absolument fondamental quand on parle
innovation alors simplement de réaction
très rapide la première qui n'a rien à
voir avec votre intervention c'est
l'innovation pourquoi faire l'innovation
pour l'innovation une espèce de cours
sans fin à l'infini derrière on ne sait
pas trop quoi est un énorme problème
civilisationnel l'innovation a priori
elle est là pour servir l'intérêt
général un bien commun un projet
collectif une justice ou je ne sais quoi
donc il va falloir aussi remettre
l'innovation dans un cadre de discussion
politique et anthropologique d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus large que que simplement
innover pour être un énième follower
derrière les leaders qui sont
immanquablement américain ou chinois en
tout cas dans la soeur technologique
donc ça c'est parenthèse fermée mais
fondamentale et simplement pour réagir à
ce que vous disiez qui est crucial c'est
la question en fait de la recherche du
développement et surtout et pour vous
déculpabiliser vous autres législateurs
c'est pas simplement une question
juridique je pense que de ce point de
vue là le travail est fait et vous le
faites très bien la question elle est
d'abord culturelle c'est la question des
silos c'est la façon de travailler c'est
les allers-retours entre le privé et le
public entre le monde de la recherche et
celui de l'entreprise et là on y est
absolument pas du tout en France je
crois il y a des frémissements des
débuts de balbutiements mais quand on
parle typiquement de la DARPA européenne
alors la DARPA c'est la grande agence
d'innovation et de recherche
affiliés donc à l'armée américaine qui
en fait sont ADN et bien les
allers-retours entre chercheurs
recherche fondamentales et secteur privé
et bien il va falloir se poser la
question de se dire comment est-ce qu'on
fait cette adjornamento culturel en
France sur sur l'état d'esprit sur la en
tout cas comment désamorcer la méfiance
que les deux mondes ont l'un envers
l'autre et moi qui est navigue entre ces
deux mondes là c'est une fondamentale
d'une part ça commence à s'y br on n'y
est pas tout à fait merci Asma alors
Jean-Noël on s'est dit beaucoup de
choses toi tu es j'ai envie de dire
concerner au premier chef par toutes ces
questions parce que quand on a le
portefeuille du numérique forcément on a
une vision très transversale puisque le
numérique aujourd'hui est partout que ce
soit en innovation sociale etc est-ce
que tu peux nous dire sur les débats
qu'on a eu aujourd'hui et quelle est ta
feuille de route comment tu vois les
choses d'abord vous signalez que pour la
première fois en disant on a un écran
avec des questions c'est dire à quel
point le modem est à l'avant-garde de ce
qui se fait en matière numérique et je
propose qu'on applaudit très fort les
organisateurs
non je souscris évidemment à beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites et si je
tentais un peu de les de les synthétiser
ou de les résumer je reviendrai un peu à
l'idée première qui fait que nous autres
nous nous retrouvons un beau week-end de
septembre à Guidel loin de tout c'est
parce qu'au fond on se dit que cet
engagement qui est le nôtre doit nous
permettre de changer le monde et de
laisser à nos enfants un monde meilleur
et parmi les dimensions de ce monde que
je crois nous voulons laisser à notre
enfant à nos enfants il y a l'idée de
leur de leur léguer une France qui soit
libre et en particulier qui soit défaite
de cette triple dette qui pèse sur son
dos et que nous risquons si nous ne
faisons rien de léguer à nos enfants la
dette financière la dette technologique
et la dette écologique
la dette financière François Bayrou a
été l'un des premiers à la dénoncer
consiste à dire que nous ne pouvons
vivre à crédit en transférant aux
générations futures la charge financière
de nos modes de consommation aujourd'hui
alors comment fait-on il y a d'abord une
attention particulière aux recettes et
aux dépenses du budget de l'État et de
la sécurité sociale et avec Jean-Paul
avec Marina avec les collègues de la
commission des finances on a fait ce
qu'on a pu dans la législature qui vient
de s'achever et nul doute que dans celle
qui commence des progrès pourront être
faits il faut aussi pour rembourser
cette dette que nous créons plus de
richesse et je reviens pas sur les
propos de de notre président François
Bayrou sur la question du travail de sa
réhabilitation qui indissociable de la
question des retraites et c'est ainsi
que toute cette dette accumulée pendant
les années de covid notamment mais
auparavant puisque nous n'avons jamais
saisi l'occasion qui était donnée par
les périodes de croissance et
d'expansion pour désendetter notre pays
et bien
en réussissant ce Grand Paris du travail
avec la réforme des retraites celle des
lycées professionnels celle du service
public de l'emploi et bien peut-être que
nous arriverons à nous en défaire la
deuxième dette c'est la dette
technologique ça a été évoqué nous ne
pouvons accepter dans le monde changeant
dans lequel nous vivons avec des menaces
nouvelles avec un fractionnement des des
blocs régionaux de dépendre pour les
technologies vitales de grandes
puissances étrangères et je veux pas
faire l'article de toutes les
technologies desquelles nous devons pas
rester dépendants et sur lesquels nous
ne devons pas accumuler du retard parce
que vous avez dans la salle des experts
de ces disciplines-ci si vous interrogez
sur la question justement du numérique
de la souveraineté numérique vous avez
Asma qui est là vous avez Philippe la
tombe je sais pas s'il est encore dans
la salle qui maîtrise parfaitement ces
sujets si vous interrogez sur les
questions de d'hydrogène de
constellation de satellites vous avez
Christophe grüller qui travaille
activement au niveau européen pour
essayer de nous donner les outils pour
acquérir cette indépendante puisque
aujourd'hui nous dépendons encore
beaucoup trop largement de puissance
étrangères sur la question industrielle
nous avons agi dans le quinquennat qui
vient de qui vient de s'achever puisque
nous avons mis fin à l'hémorragie de
l'emploi industriel et on ouvre en
France désormais plus d'usine qu'on
enferme c'est le début de ce qu'est la
reconquête de notre capacité à produire
en France là aussi un thème que François
Bayero a su mettre sur le devant de la
scène et s'agissant de l'industrie
aéronautique vous savez qu'avec Jean-Luc
avec Laurent est-ce que né vous avez
sans doute parmi les meilleures experts
donc la dette technologique qui a
deuxième dette que nous ne pouvons
laisser ou transférer à nos enfants et
puis la dernière c'est la dette
écologique là aussi je vais pas balayer
tous les sujets mais puisque Laetitia en
a parlé sur le sujet du numérique
sur le sujet du numérique nous avons une
empreinte carbone qui est un peu moins
importante que ce que certains
voudraient parfois laisser penser
l'empreinte carbone du numérique c'est
aujourd'hui 2 à 3% de l'empreinte
carbone de la France mais c'est
évidemment une empreinte qui est amenée
à beaucoup augmenter dans les années qui
viennent alors que faut-il faire faut-il
éteindre les ordres les ordinateurs
éteindre les téléphones basculer sur le
wifi non je crois que Laetitia l'a
évoqué il faut prendre le sujet à bras
le corps et s'interroger là où sont les
véritables problèmes ou l'empreinte
carbone du numérique se situe-t-elle
elle se situe essentiellement dans les
smartphones et dans les tablettes et en
particulier dans la fabrication des
smartphones et des tablettes c'est 80%
de l'empreinte carbone 80% des émissions
carbone du numérique et des télécoms ça
vient de la fabrication des téléphones
et des smart et des smartphones des
smartphones et des tablettes et donc si
on veut réduire l'empreinte carbone du
numérique alors il faut faire ce travail
d'inventaire ce travail de réflexion
identifié là où sont les vrais problèmes
pour identifier ensuite ce que sont les
bonnes solutions et parmi les bonnes
solutions en tout cas moi je crois qu'il
faut continuer à les pousser la question
de l'obsolescence la question de la
copie privée et d'autres sujets qui pour
l'instant nous empêche d'arriver à ce
qu'on a à faire ce qu'on a fait dans
l'automobile où il y a encore quelques
décennies on achetait 80 % de véhicules
neufs et 20 % de véhicules d'occasion il
faut que dans les quelques années qui
viennent et bien on passe de 80% de
smartphone et tablettes 9 à 80 % de
smartphone et tablettes d'occasion si
nous arrivons à libérer la France si
l'on peut dire de cette de cette triple
dette qui a été très bien évoquée par
nos experts sur sur le plateau alors
nous aurons fait
œuvres utile et pour peut-être amender
la devise de Mayotte Hélène et
félicitations pour pour le petit film la
France que nous voulons céder à nos
enfants c'est une France qui est libre
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes engagés nous sommes là
aujourd'hui à Guidel et engagé pour la
suite
merci beaucoup cher Jean-Noël
alors il nous reste assez peu de temps
pour répondre aux quelques questions qui
qui nous ont été posées alors peut-être
une question Jean-Noël pour toi on parle
beaucoup planification pour affronter
les défis de demain un succès français
planification la fibre ça tombe bien
alors donc pour se détacher de cette
triple dette que j'évoquais il y a deux
leviers importants le premier c'est
l'Europe et les parlementaires européens
le savent bien pendant la présidence
française de l'Union européenne nous
avons mis les gafams à genoux sur un
certain nombre de sujets et nous ne
l'avons fait que parce que nous l'avons
fait en européen et parce que nous avons
fait comprendre au Gafa que sur un
certain nombre de sujets s'ils veulent
accéder sur au plus grand marché unique
du monde s'ils veulent accéder au grand
marché unique de la plus grande
démocratie du monde alors ils doivent
respecter un certain nombre de règles
que nous voulons imposer et c'est ces
règles seront mises en oeuvre dans les
dans les mois qui viennent c'est vous
vous en entendrez parler c'est le
règlement DSA et le règlement DMA et
c'est une véritable avancée que nous
n'avons plus
guérir qu'en européen le premier levier
c'est l'Europe et le deuxième c'est la
planification et c'est une excellente
nouvelle que d'avoir
amené ensemble le Commissariat aux plans
d'un côté qui fait le travail de
prospective et le Conseil national de
Lara fondation de l'autre qui fait le
travail de concertation parce que la
vision que nous avons pour résoudre pour
relever ces grands défis c'est celle de
Jean Monnet au moment de la
reconstruction
poser un diagnostic clair qui s'appuie
sur des connaissances scientifiques et
ensuite faire dialoguer les parties
prenantes pour qu'elles comprennent les
contraintes qui sont celles des uns et
des autres et qu'elles puissent se
projeter ensemble sur un objectif commun
et donc sur la question de la
planification sur de la transition
écologique en particulier et pour ce qui
me concerne de la planification
écologique pour le secteur du numérique
nous nous engageons comme l'ensemble des
des ministères dans une grande démarche
de planification écologique celle que le
Président de la République a annoncé
et celle dont la première ministre à la
charge désormais avec le soutien et
l'encouragement et l'aiguillon du
Conseil national de la refondation
Europe et planification ce sont les deux
leviers de puissance dont nous disposons
pour réussir ces trois grands défis que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure merci
Jeannelle autre question alors je sais
pas qui qui voudrait y répondre c'est
une question sur les investissements que
nous conduisons aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on est au rendez-vous
pour affronter la concurrence notamment
des modèles américains et chinois donc
c'est un peu une thématique qu'on a
abordé un peu tout à l'heure peu importe
comme vous voulez qui sont
très circuler la parole alors
moi comme ça la question merci de
l'avoir posé pardon mais c'est de mon
travers peut-être de prof c'est pas
est-ce qu'on investit assez c'est est-ce
qu'on investit bien
je reviens toujours à ma à ma mate donc
la question c'est pas tant la quantité
les moyens sont extrêmement restreints
en Europe on n'a pas on n'a pas
aujourd'hui les moyens les milliards que
les États-Unis en partie et encore plus
la Chine aujourd'hui sont capables
d'aligner sur l'IA le cantique etc donc
avec ce qu'on a dans une économie de
frugalité on va dire comment est-ce
qu'on investit le mieux possible le plus
efficacement possible et donc je reviens
à cette réponse que je donnais du coup
de façon anticipée à la question sur
quels sont les choix et donc quels sont
les renoncements comment est-ce qu'on
invest comment on investi pardon de
façon efficace pour avoir le meilleur
retour sur investissement pour la nation
d'accord merci alors évidemment
le gouvernement a mis en place un plan
d'aide à l'aéronautique de 20 milliards
d'euros pour l'aider dans sa
transmission dans sa transition
numérique et donc ça part Airbus tous
les sous-traitants d'Airbus en France et
cet ouvert également
des gens qui ne sont pas des
sous-traitants Airbus nous avons en
France des des sociétés qui créent de
nouveaux avions des startups de
l'aéronautique qui sont donc pas des
sous-traitants qui dans le premier plan
initial n'était pas visé et qu'on a
réussi à intégrer dans le plan donc il y
a des choses qui se passent
merci Jean-Luc alors une question
Laetitia celle-ci elle est vraiment pour
vous peut-on garder une croissance
économique avec l'augmentation de la
durabilité des produits je pense que
vous allez nous dire oui vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi
sans suspense en effet tout à fait en
fait c'est une autre économie qu'il faut
travailler évidemment une transition en
fait des acteurs aussi qui sont
classiques dans cette économie linéaire
de la vente de produits de plus en plus
souvent et de plus en plus nombreux et
dans les voies de justement de la
croissance
qui est compatible avec cette durabilité
des produits il y a la réparation déjà
il y a beaucoup d'innovations maintenant
dans la réparation au niveau de la
robotisation des chaînes pour que ce
soit plus performant de l'accès aux
pièces détachées il y a également tout
ce qui est économie autour de
l'entretien par exemple des groupes qui
maintenant proposent des abonnements
pour
accompagner finalement les clients non
non pas à renouveler l'équipement le
plus vite possible mais à l'accompagner
dans l'entretien puisqu'il faut savoir
que près de 50% des pannes n'ont pas
besoin de pièces détachées et en fait
sont dus à un manque d'entretien tout
simplement donc c'est la question de
comment on accompagne cette cette
entretien et cette sensibilisation et
donc des abonnements des choses
intéressantes des nouveaux modèles
économiques basés sur le service et ça
c'est vraiment des choses importantes et
puis comme on le disait le
reconditionnement une grosse voix
d'avenir aussi de croissance de plus en
plus de produits qui sont vendus y
compris dans des dans des boutiques
classiques des grandes chaînes de
magasins qui se mettent au
reconditionner parce que c'est une voix
plus sobre de consommer qui permet
d'éviter beaucoup de matières premières
puisque comme on l'a dit la fabrication
c'est vraiment la bête noire de de du
problème donc oui il y a des solutions
il y a beaucoup d'emplois dans la
réparation par exemple c'est trois fois
plus d'emplois que si on est sur du
recyclage donc clairement il y a il y a
un boulevard dans l'économie circulaire
pour créer de la croissance mais
attention les l'ADEM a démontré qu'il y
a
[Musique]
la dame a démontré dans un document que
je vous invite à lire qui s'appelle
transition 2050 que il y a plusieurs
scénarios pour arriver au
objectif voilà aux objectifs de
climatique et qu'il faut vraiment avoir
un juste milieu entre sobriété
efficacité ne pas enfin la croissance
verte à tout prix croire que la
technologie va tous nous sauver d'après
la dame c'est pas ça ne correspond pas
au fait aux objectifs climatiques donc
on peut le vouloir mais il faut savoir
qu'on sera au dessus des 2 degrés et
qu'on vivra relativement mal sur la
planète
merci beaucoup oui Fabienne
un tout petit mot mais juste rappeler
que dans la région Bretagne on va
emmener la région où le ou le poids de
l'ESS est le plus important en France
donc c'est aussi ça c'est quel modèle
d'entreprendre et
je trouve que c'est un bon on peut
promouvoir en tout cas l'économie
sociale et solidaire sur ce sur les
transitions à venir oui parce que un
segment d'emploi aussi un gisement
d'emploi très important alors on a une
question président peut-être que tu
pourrais répondre donc quel serait les
mesures urgentes à prendre pour que les
entreprises innovantes grandissent plus
vite en France ça c'est typiquement pour
un président de groupe
il me semble que on a déjà pas mal
d'outils à notre disposition pour
permettre
l'agrandissement de
l'accroissement des entreprises elle se
fait comment par croissance interne ou
croissance externe donc favoriser
peut-être le regroupement des
entreprises et autres mais dans notre
législation qui est peut-être pas assez
bien connu un problème de d'information
de communication pour permettre je
dirais le développement de ces
entreprises vous savez c'est de la PME
de la petite entreprise on grandit et
puis c'est ce qu'on appelle le ti la
entreprise totale intermédiaire qui peut
aussi mais bon je dirais c'est un autre
mode de gouvernance et autre par contre
il y a un sujet qui me semble important
qu'on connaît bien dans l'aéronautique
c'est l'organisation de la
sous-traitance et les et les rapports
entre grand donneurs d'or et petit
donneur d'ordre et donc moi je fais
petite entreprise donc je pense que là
il faut qu'on ait une réflexion qui
sécurise les rapports entre grand
donneur d'ordre et entreprises et des
entreprises moyennes in
pour qu'elle puisse
croître respirer parce qu'on a souvent
tendance on a souvent des déséquilibres
contractuels qui sont importants et je
crois que ça c'est un moyen de
développement
de ces entreprises voilà moi je crois
qu'on a les outils à notre disposition
il faut que
ce qui a été mis en place par le
gouvernement sur France 2030 avec les
investissements et tout ça ça va dans le
bon sens
l'investissement public aussi l'aide
publique il y a également un sujet moi
qui me tient à coeur c'est la création
de société régionale d'intervention
haute bilan pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui c'est au niveau des régions
ces grandes régions manquent un peu de
lisibilité et décliné localement donc
moi par exemple je pousse à ce que
parfois les départements retrouvent une
compétence économique régionalement et
qu'on puisse avoir des fonds
d'intervention haute bilan pour
permettre aux entreprises de grandir et
de s'élever de façon on a souvent besoin
de capitaux mais également de rapport
contractuels quand j’évoquais tout à
l'heure les chiffres d'affaires il faut
que les chiffres d'affaires soient
sécurisés lorsqu'on est dans des
secteurs je dirais innovants donc à
risque je voudrais rebondir sur le
nombre d'entreprises dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique il y a en France 4500
entreprises qui travaillent dans le
domaine de l'aéronautique et donc il y
en a une qui s'appelle Airbus mais vous
en avez d'autres qui sont des toutes
petites PME des TPE où il y a deux trois
personnes qui travaillent et qui font un
produit et donc l'idée du gouvernement
dans ce plan France 2030 c'était
justement d'essayer de rapprocher un
certain nombre d'entreprises pour
qu'elles ne soient pas systématiquement
lié à un seul marché voilà aujourd'hui
tous les toutes les entreprises de
l'aéronautique qui travaillent sur
la 350 donc est un avion très long
courrier sauf pourquoi mais parce qu'il
y a très peu de ventes de la 350 parce
qu'il y a il n'y a pas de magnifique
international là voilà donc
effectivement il faut
diversifier
les marchés il faut rapprocher un
certain nombre d'entreprises alors on va
pas pouvoir prendre
ce pas tout à fait 3 minutes avant de
pouvoir notamment libérer Jean-Noël donc
une question Jean-Noël sur la mise à
niveau des compétences pour réussir ce
pari
oui c'est un grand chantier
vous en souvenez on a d'ailleurs pris
avec le président de la République un
mandat auprès des Français à ce sujet
puisqu'on s'est engagé collectivement à
former 400 000 professionnels du
numérique en plus sur la durée du
quinquennat alors maintenant
si vous voulez bien on s'applaudir après
si on y parvient parce que c'est
justement la question comment est-ce
qu'on fait comment est-ce qu'on fait
sachant que aujourd'hui on ne je vois
qu'il y a un chiffre qui est cité dans
la dans la question mais en réalité on
ne connaît pas le nombre de personnes
formées aujourd'hui en France au métier
du numérique au sens large et c'est
normal parce que des métiers du
numérique il y en a beaucoup à tous les
niveaux de qualification dans tous les
territoires et donc ce que nous allons
faire avec d'un côté l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche de l'autre la
formation professionnelle c'est
commencer par
inventorier l'ensemble des formations
existantes dans notre pays aujourd'hui
qu'elles soient l'université qu'elle
soit dans les façons de formation
qu'elle soit dans les entreprises que ce
soit des initiatives à dock comme on a
vu fleurir un certain nombre ces
dernières années pour pouvoir identifier
dans quel territoire dans quel domaine
pour quel niveau de qualification il y a
des manques et pour boire à partir de là
donner un certain nombre d'impulsions
d'impulsion qui s'appuieront d'ailleurs
sur les un certain nombre de réforme que
nous avons menées ensemble et on parlait
tout à l'heure avec les collègues
députés du manifeste du MRP de 1944 dès
1944 le MRP s'engageait déjà pour la
formation tout au long de la vie et si
nous avons fait l'apprentissage les
premières années de la première du
premier mandat si on peut dire et si
nous faisons les lycées professionnels
première année du deuxième mandat alors
nous aurons été fidèles si je puis dire
à nos origines et c'est à partir de ces
fondements là que nous réussirons ce
défi et il y a un défi associé à
celui-ci c'est évidemment celui de
d'attirer les filles
d'attirer les femmes dans les métiers du
numérique puisque aujourd'hui elle s'en
détourne complètement alors que vous le
savez l'intelligence est qui
équitablement répartie entre les deux
sexes et c'est bien dommage que le
numérique se prive de la moitié du
talent donc voilà un grand chantier à
venir pour nous merci beaucoup Jean-Noël
je crois que tu dois nous quitter je
crois que tu dois nous quitter tout de
suite on a le temps de prendre la
dernière que tu veux rester avec nous
pour la dernière question
non non
alors Jean-Noël merci beaucoup pour ta
présence c'était vraiment super heureux
de ta part d'être avec nous et good luck
comment on dit en patois savoyard pour
la semaine prochaine voilà on peut
l'applaudir mais parce qu'il s'est rendu
disponible pour être avec nous et merci
il y a juste une dernière question voilà
bon
c'est celle qui était sur les ressources
rares alors que faire pour assurer notre
souveraineté
c'est une excellente question
qui est hyper critique
il y a deux choses il y a alors en fait
je refais je refais le raisonnement
parce que il faut remettre les choses
dans leur contexte la question
fondamentale qui est posée là c'est la
question des semis conducteurs en gros
donc en fait ce sont ces micro puces
c'est nanopus qui sont utiles pour
l'ensemble des équipements les
smartphones les micro-ondes tout un tas
de les voitures etc et donc sur la
question de semi conducteurs qui
cristallisent un peu cette tension
géostratégique
en effet vous avez aujourd'hui un leader
qui est taïwanais et donc avec la crise
cet été typiquement qu'on a eu entre la
Chine et les États-Unis sur la question
de Taïwan et notamment sur la question
des semi-conducteurs c'est donc posé la
question de notre stratégie sur cette
industrie là la stratégie américaine et
qui pourrait en fait servir d'exemples à
l'Europe qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
exactement pris toute la maturité sur ce
sujet là c'est d'une part de
régionaliser c'est à dire en fait de
rapatrier un certain nombre d'usines
mais de très hautes de très haute un
très haut niveau si vous voulez de
d'innovation sur le sol ou en tout cas
dans la dans dans les régions amis on va
dire donc ça c'est le premier sujet et
puis le deuxième sujet c'est de trouver
d'autres innovations qui permettent de
court-circuiter l'usage de ces de ces
matériaux là en l'occurrence sur la
question des semis conducteurs qui est
pour moi le cas d'école aujourd'hui les
principaux les principaux producteurs
des des de ces ressources rares sont en
réalité la Russie l'Ukraine le Japon
alors sur le Japon on n'a pas encore de
grands problèmes d'alliance et de et de
et d'industrie et de commerce sur
l'Ukraine et la Russie ce qu'on a vu
apparaître en fait c'est un chantage
c'est coercition et surtout une
explosion des prix donc
c'est toujours des stratégies à double
détente qu'est-ce qu'on fait à court
terme qu'est-ce qu'on fait à long terme
régionaliser innover et tenir ce fameux
rapport de force très bien merci Asma
c'était le mot de la fin un grand merci
à tous d'avoir participé à cette table
ronde et Fabienne pour un bizutage bravo
merci
[Applaudissements]